James Gunn is sharing new details about
the upcoming Superman movie which
officially kicks off gun and Peter
saffron's DC Universe yeah that's a big
deal so the newest installment of the
franchise titled Superman Legacy will be
directed by Gunn himself yes in a series
of heartfelt tweets gun revealed the
news to fans explaining the sentimental
meaning behind the film's release date
writing yes I am directing Superman
Legacy to be released on July 11 2025.
my brother Matt told me when he saw the
release date he started to cry I asked
him why he said dude it's Dad's birthday
I hadn't realized ah I know James added
I lost my dad almost three years ago he
was my best friend I wouldn't be making
this movie now without him I love this
script and I'm incredibly excited as we
begin this journey yeah the Tweet also
includes an image from the comic book
series All-Star Superman which fans are
speculating could be an indication of
the film's inspiration with Gunn also
teasing that the film will center around
Superman's Heritage okay now this news
follows the shocking reveal that Henry
Cavill will not be reprising his role as
Superman in gun and saffron's DC
Universe which does beg the question who
will be taking on the role of Clark Kent
yeah so we've been having a lot of a lot
of people have said David Corn Sweat
Right and um
Jacob you lordy yes we're kind of like
two of The Front Runners for the nuke
they're both young right both like
various Superman looking guys you know
yeah I like it what about Glenn Powell
he obviously just came off top gun
Maverick he's done rom-com so not only
is he very funny but he's got that kind
of perfect Clark Ken and this is what my
question is put aside who's going to be
cast as Superman what about James Gunn I
mean we know that he's brilliant I mean
look what he did with James uh with uh
Guardians of the Galaxy yeah and the
suicide squad and Suicide Squad so
outside of the box but with a character
like Superman is he the right guy to
tackle that character I think that's the
big discussion around Superman fans and
James Gunn like a few years ago James
Gunn had said that he not that he wasn't
interested but that maybe he wasn't
ready or he didn't he wouldn't know how
to approach yeah Superman and now he has
written the script it is that he really
loves and yes he's going to direct it
and I think a lot of people who love
maybe the sincerity of Superman
um are maybe a bit worried that James
Gunn's take might not be that since I'm
not sure right it might not be that
sister but we've seen that with you know
his outside the box takes on everything
right which we love but will it fit with
this kind of character yeah listen I am
so curious about this
um like I said he also has a a
an ability to pick actors and turn them
into Superstars I mean look what he did
with Chris Pratt yeah so it'll be
curious to see who he picks I I think
this whole thing about Superman's
Heritage and the All-Star Superman yeah
what do you think I think there's
something interesting in there so he had
said about the Heritage thing it was
like
um being from Krypton and also from
Kansas right and how how both of those
things affect who Superman is
All-Star Superman is a story about
Superman facing death like Superman has
been told he basically has a year to
live oh and so he goes around he goes on
super Banning things but he's like you
know he kind of like figures it all out
right and so if we're talking about it
being about also this is my weird nerd
take I'm just throwing it out I'm here
for it go what if they are doing a
version of All-Star Superman and what if
the new Superman we're talking about is
not Clark Kent but John can't who is
Superman's son who is Clark and Lois's
actual son and so we're thinking an
entirely younger generation than what
all these guys are being thrown out as
uh being casted oh it'd be like a kid or
a teenager like a teenager no way and
this would I who knows I feel like this
is never gonna happen yeah but it's
James Gunn so you gotta think outside
the box but if it was an All-Star
Superman what if it was Henry Cavill as
Clark and he's facing his last year so
to speak and they and they include the
whole idea of jonker now of course
All-Star Superman isn't all this but I'm
just kind of like
interesting listen we have seen numerous
takes of the same character kind of the
same story so to do something completely
outside of the box or or something we
haven't seen as an audience on screen
before I'd be really happy for that he
had he did say in that big DCU
presentation he made a month ago you
know else worlds do exist that's where
the Batman comes in and that's where
Joker and those movies come in
um so there are possibilities for
different stories with different
characters right but we don't really
still don't know after you know this
whole flash thing the flash flash point
we don't know how the DCU is going to
shake out it's true what direction it's
going to be going who's going to be who
what's going to be what we have no idea
that's exciting interesting